we have the top five most aggressive
chess openings you ready let's get right
into it this first one is from Captain
Evans in the 19th century and that is
the Evans Gambit sometimes you sacrifice
one two even three pawns to attack the
king here we go airplanes Gambit starts
with E4 E5 Knight F3 Knight C6 stuff you
already see Ryan in Bishop C4 Italian
game is where it starts from black can't
play Knight F6 but after Knight F6 they
run into fry liver with Knight G5 so
they really don't want to go down that
line a lot of times you'll see Bishop C5
doing the same thing that you are
developing then I'm gonna move my knight
so I can meet Knight G5 with castling
right and then if you you give up two
for one I'm gonna be better there with
the black pieces but after Bishop to C5
the move here played by even Gary Castro
back in the day is before there it is B4
aggressive we gotta remember that right
now before you actually discard this
move look at B4 look at the move d4 here
what is it doing well number one is
attacking the bishop but it can be
captured by two two separate pieces now
believe it or not after Knight takes we
do play C3 here because Knight takes E5
we'll run into some issues but with the
C3 move we actually can transpose into
what we're already gonna have if Bishop
takes B4 in many cases now most people
do not take with the ninth in fact they
actually take with the bishop most times
here after Bishop takes B4 um this is an
aggressive attacking Tempo move for
Tempo opening where like every move you
want to be attacking or doing something
after Bishop takes B4 we go with the C3
move attacking the bishop lots of open
lines diagonals um tactics are in this
opening here an initiative and develop
very quickly after C3 Bishop C5 very
common move they have Bishop A5 and
Bishop E7 as well but Bishop C5 is very
common after the bishop C5 move we
strike the center with D4 big Center and
they're like oh no we're not gonna let
you have that center now after he takes
D4 what do you think you do here
here it is in fact it's a trick question
we cast when we get out the way and have
a nice day what is this why are we
giving up what is this what do you mean
why are we doing this well let's see
what happens if D takes C3 now of course
we've given up three pawns B4 C3 and D4
we gave it up giving them three pawns
now after this after uh D takes C3 have
the beautiful move Bishop takes F7
beautiful right to check draws the king
out after King takes we go Queen D5 we
check him and we pick up the bishop here
and we get our piece back right quick
sample line King goes back there's no
casting for you bud Queen takes C5 and
then D6 after the D6 move attacks the
queen we go Queen to C3 all right let's
go back a few moves here instead of
um D take C3 there's another cool move
that can happen which is you know Knight
G to E7 what does this move say it's
like hey you can do all the tricks in
the world that you want you can do
whatever you like but I'm going to
Castle I'm going to just get my king
safe very quickly Knight G2 E7
developing pieces following some
principles after Knight G2 E7 we take on
D4 C takes D4 very aggressive Big Pawn
Center here Bishop moves back to B6
after B6 it's right to move nice
combination that you should know here
the move here in fact is
95 and we live that's what we say all
the time Knight G5 and we lie beautiful
Square here it just hits F7 but Black's
like huh I already knew you were gonna
do that you have lost your mind castles
right castles we're gonna defend this
pawn and of course taking this is
usually wrong they call us the two for
one we're giving up the bishop and the
Knight for just the rook in the pawn of
course it's the same material wise but
we actually are still down to piece in a
way so these the minor pieces could
actually prove better later on in the
game but this is something that we want
to stay away from so if this is
something we want to stay away from how
do we have them Knight G5 we thought
we're doing something or is it it's why
to move here how do you finish off black
what do you do
the move here is Queen H5
and we there you go and we live exactly
Queen H5 and we live absolutely
beautiful hitting F7 hitting H7 hitting
everything seven in the way you're gonna
be in a lot of trouble in fact or one of
the moves here is H6 just giving up a
full exchange we have one two three
right pieces on F7 after Knight takes F7
we have Rook takes Queen takes F7 and
check that's the Evans Gambit very fun
very cool pushing that B4 Pawn out there
throwing them off because they have no
idea what you're doing they're used to
seeing the other stuff next up coming in
at number four we have the Danish Gambit
this one you sacrifice two in three
pawns and you have both the Bishops and
you have great attacking chances let's
see what that looks like after E4 right
E4 Black Goes E5 very stable now of
course uh the next move here is actually
very interesting you play D4 so after
the D4 move there's e takes D4 thinking
but in fact black is like oh you're
gonna take with your queen and allow
nice C6 with Tempo like what are you
doing this guy doesn't know how to play
chess is what they're saying with the
black pieces and then you also have
Knight F3 if you play Knight at three I
could play C5 and defend this Pawn with
a pawn and he's like again this what is
this guy doing so then you play C3 and
they're like well you're offering me
another Pawn what is this then after
Pawn takes right what do we do do we
take the pawn back with the pawn or do
we take it with a knight or do we take
it at all it is right to move what do
you do in this position
the move here is Bishop C4 oh look at
that one yeah that one is developing
right it looks sort of like the first
thing you look at in Evans where we just
kind of giving up material for
initiative or for Rapid development
that's usually what this is about
especially when you see gambits this
being the Danish Gambit a lot of times
that Gambit is about giving up a pawn or
two sometimes three for Rapid
development and lots of attack after
Bishop C4 C takes B2 and they're like
hey you're gonna give me these pawns I'm
gonna take them right then we take it
back because we need to take that one
back so we don't allow some decisive
material loss Bishop takes B2 and if you
look at this position from a little from
a far here and up close even as well the
Bishops actually are sharp minus sync if
the king castles you may not survive in
many cases if you don't know what you're
doing even then it's still difficult
sometimes to hold and you have to be
careful of what you do push this pawn it
can't go backwards and Etc right so uh
the Bishops look nice you also have
Knight F3 you could castle with some
point too you have Queen B3 or queen G4
in some cases Queen f three right as
well it's lots of development very quick
and we have almost everything out on the
contrary look at all the black pieces
yes of course we're now you know Pawn or
two right it happens right we're down a
few pawns but at the same time we have
rapid development very fast even engine
says it's about equal that's crazy right
the development okay guys here we are
with number three this one is called the
Halloween Gambit now what kind of name
is that the Halloween game it is a fun
one very fun and we're actually going to
show a quick game from MBL Maxine Bashir
LeBron from 2019 where he says I found
my new secret weapon I found my new
weapon right which is a very spun in
Blitz and of course this is a Blitz game
too as well let's let's take a look at
what that is in fact after E4 E5 Knight
F3 standard stuff Knight C6 and then
white goes nice C3 a little bit
different right of course you don't see
this all the time is this three nights
developing easy black lace Knight F6 is
four nights so now we have four Knights
on the board here and we generally it
would just develop a bishop or do your
pieces here and get castle now here's
something I hope you ready for this one
this is a Family Channel what this is is
the move here is Knight takes E5 bro
what is this you have to be kidding me
right this is a full piece for a pot you
have to be kidding right this can't be a
thing well let's take a look at it after
Knight takes E5 Knight takes E5 now
believe it or not being down a piece
here in fact white is still okay if you
find the Right Moves now of course the
move here is D4 right you're like what I
didn't even get a piece back this
doesn't make any sense to me wait for a
second after the D4 move Knight G6 was
played after Knight G6 the idea here
with this opening is you have the big
Pawn Mass right you have the pawn mask
in the center here you can also play F4
someplace in some um cases you can play
G4 two as well you can also Play Bishop
C for you you're gonna develop quickly
now anytime you Gambit material lots of
times an aggressive aggressive like
manner of style you got to be fast
initiative it's about that time how
quickly can you do things so after
Knight to G6 E5 right we build some more
time take the Knight away Knight has to
go somewhere you can't go to any of the
central squares you can't go Knight G4
you can't go Knight H5 right see you go
Knight G8 Knight already is on the back
back foot here now aggressive think
aggressive here guys this is about
aggressive openings I want you to think
aggressive at home why Timo what's an
aggressive move you would play in this
position
the move here is
H4 that's just out of the bull you're
like well this this I was like an E6 you
know Bishop C4 maybe something like that
now the idea here is after Knight takes
H4 we're just gonna keep moving stuff
like D5 D5 put both these Pawns in the
center you also could play Queen E2 you
just sacrificing open up lines and
diagonal stuff that you've seen in the
Danish Gambit and of course the uh Evans
as well so after uh this is not what
happened in the game after H4 black
played H5 we just we're not we don't
want to take any more problems you're
doing a little bit too much right after
the H5 move
um white develops Bishop to C4 hitting
F7 it's a weak point Black Goes Bishop
B4 I need to develop my pieces here
Bishop to G5 hits the queen black and
then of course 97 just everything's all
blocked up this is really strange really
strange and it's still wipes down a
piece you know but we have a lot of
initiative like which is equal to time
after Bishop to E7 Bishop goes back to
block you know the bishop line diagonal
there then we play Queen to F3 Queen F3
is hitting one F7 right we take this
that's gonna be made and have a nice day
so black is 4 to play a gross move which
is F6 this is disgusting because after
Knight H6 obviously we snapped the
Knight and then we do queen F7 and
mating right so F6 oh man that's gross
but hey stop the mate didn't it the move
here is which is really strong is Queen
to D5 oh my goodness hitting mate wow
we're gonna finish this game out here I
mean it's literally only seven moves
left and it ended in checkmate
now after the queen D5 moved D6 because
like how again how do you defend mate
Knight H6 we snap off the bit the Knight
with the bishop
so D6 Queen check and you're like oh oh
made it ah but it's not E6 King goes to
C6 the king is out in the middle of the
street chat D5 check right at the very
least we can come back and take the
Knight we can take this we can take
everything but we're gonna go for make
Knight A4 run the King around the board
here King A5 Bishop D2 check King takes
A4
A3
the Heat the heat because the problem is
if you go B3 or something B3 runs to A3
so the idea is go A3 and then after A5
B3 check and make what a game that's the
Halloween Gambit hopefully you try that
today and you win trick or treat or not
this is a fun one that's number three
let's move to number two here we are
with number two of our aggressive chest
openings this one is the Cochrane Gambit
that is played in the petrov's defense
or the Russian defense size what they
call it as well John Cochran uh was was
like one of the first to employ this in
the 19th century of course let's see
what this is so the move here is E4 to
start off E5 Knight F3 and black with a
copycat strategy this is called the
Petrov or uh Petrov or the Russian
defense as well after Knight F6 we have
Knight takes E5 now you have the
Stafford Gambit right which is nice C6
and you have the standard move D6 the D6
was played but here this one's really
interesting here because most times you
go Knight F3 you also can play Knight C4
and you all also seen in the um Knight
of three Knight F3 Knight C4 and you've
seen any in the world championship with
a Magnus and Fabiano Carolina back in
2018 Knight to D3 so very playable moves
here but one move that you're not
considering and especially your opponent
that you can try today if you face this
is
Knight takes F7
what is that what are we doing usually
you would do this when a bishop is on C4
or queen or something is defending the
Knight there is nothing defending my
knight so he can take it which he does
believe it or not you won't believe that
the engine says that this is equal the
idea here with taking this is that your
king first can't castle and as you've
seen the Halloween game we're gonna have
a huge central control like lots of
Center control here the main move
believe it or not is D4 and you're like
wait isn't this Pawn just hanging real
quick trap after Knight takes E4 you get
the piece almost right back and go Queen
H5 and queen D5 if you like right and
then you also have Bishop C4 check as
well but it's easier to just get the
piece back
check G6
Queen D5 pick up tonight very easy very
easy plan there that's number two let's
move to the most aggressive opening
number one let's look at it here we are
with our final aggressive opening number
one okay what you think it is Chad what
do you think this one is the King's
Gambit and today we're going to look at
the Museo Gambit what is that what
that's when we sacrifice a night on the
F3 Square very crazy stuff happens in
the king's Gambit already but this one
in particular in the Museo Gambit this
is actually a game I pulled from shirock
back in 1990 and this is a very very
strong game look at this game after E4
E5 F4 you're like whoa hey you're gonna
have to relax okay we don't do that kind
of stuff over here but in fact we do
very aggressive after he takes F4 Knight
F3 right stopping a queen H4 Bishop C4
sorry G5 defends the pawn and after G5
we go Bishop C4 after Bishop C4 move
which hits F7 it's already kind of wacky
like why is the Pawn on G5 we developed
and then black plays G4 says you know
what hey I don't know what you're doing
you know I want you to move your knight
so I can play Queen H4 check you know
and try to stop the castle here I can
always play King F12 as well but white
doesn't care about this move whatsoever
this is called the Museo Gambit and in
gambits we Gambit for Rapid development
very fast initiative right with time
that's what we want chapter G4 we Castle
the king
giving up a full night don't try this
one at home but actually maybe try this
one in particular at home castles after
castles there's G takes F3 he says I'm
gonna take it I don't know what you're
doing you have lost your mind and after
G takes half three Queen takes F3 right
so you're not even hitting this file yet
right the pawn is blocking it so in the
game there was Queens who have six right
defending saying hey Queen trade trade
when you up not when you're down sheer
off finds E5 E5 hits the queen right
he's like wait a second that was a cool
looking move after Queen takes E5 you
don't have a rook E1 what are you doing
that was funny that was cute right and
then here's the Shocker Bishop F7 okay
that's the second piece right I lost the
Knight now he's giving up a bishop so
I'm down two pieces already okay well
that is correct but also those two
pieces are not developed yet so if they
get developed Black's gonna be 100
winning but they're not developed yet so
the next move here is D4 from White wow
look how crazy that one is D4 it's like
wait a second you're giving up two
pieces and a pawn here because Queen
takes D4 is with check so he plays it
the move from White here and this is
shear off remember very aggressive has
the book fire on the board one of the
greatest aggressive books out after
Queen takes D4 Bishop to E3 what a move
there's a pin here obviously blocking
and I get another piece out developed
you got to move your queen yet again
Queen F6 and then Bishop takes F4
there's all types of checks there's
weird stuff going on on this file in the
diagonal whoa white Black's like I don't
want anything to do with this so he
moves the king back to EA getting out of
the way we have to be fast when you
Gambit and you give up material you
gotta be fast so we developed Knight C3
get another piece out Knight D5 is
coming we got the the a rook swinging
over here too as well Knight to C6 I
have to develop two says black gotta get
my pieces out Knight to D5 hits the
queen right C7 we getting a piece back
at least getting something back black
plays Queen G6 Rook 80 E1 check first
right we throw a check in there and then
Bishop E7 and now he here right here
this is why the Kings game it could be
one of the craziest openings ever on the
face of the Earth or any planet that is
after Bishop E7 what do you play in this
position white to move oh my goodness
the move here is
Bishop D6
what is that
ain't even breathe Bishop D6 this move
right here
is one of the greatest moves I've ever
seen Bishop D6 is such a great move the
idea here is if you take it with
anything it doesn't I don't care what
you take it with besides the bishop
obviously you can't
it's Checkmate on the back rank what do
you mean let's show it pawn takes D6
there's mates on f8 because the Rook is
pinning the bishop all right cool cool
cool that's that's cool that was sweet
as a queen how about Queen takes Bishop
same thing
always mate
wow that's sick okay cool cool cool cool
cool perfect so we see this and this is
scary especially when this happens
you're like oh he means business for
real I'm about to get checkmated so he
plays King d8 and says hey man just take
it the move here he is guys
Queen f8
he didn't sacked everything he sacked a
bishop a night a pawn another Pawn like
the queen you know and winning the game
after Bishop takes that fa
right
we play
Bishop takes C7 guys you're also could
have taken on fa2 as well if you like
but Bishop C7 is even a prettier
Checkmate I mean look at the geometry
here and how great this game is this is
the musio game and I'm sure some of you
guys are inspired right now and ready to
play some Kings Gambit so of course
definitely do that put the comments
under the video and make sure you guys
subscribe to the channel here hit the
follow button over here hit the likes do
all that stuff and this was a great
video very fun to do this for the
aggressive openings hopefully you
enjoyed it and if you enjoyed this one
watch it back again and also check the
other videos right after this one we'll
see you on the next video